6 40 here on a monday morning good
morning to you at home and monica
jackson good morning to you
as well uh how did you how did you dodge
the rain yesterday
are you kidding me it was the funniest
thing i was telling sherry during
commercial break
i tried to take get some video and every
time i
like open my window just a little bit
lightning would strike after the second
time my husband's like don't open that
window again
but yeah it was something else in
henderson we got clobbered
but hey folks uh 6 39 right now just i
wanted to bring this up because i think
it's really important so much is going
on so we might forget but
as small businesses continue to reopen
here in vegas
having a working knowledge of available
resources is crucial to their
sustainability and that's why
i've invited the president and ceo mary
beth seawall of the vegas chamber
to this edition of mondays with monica
mary beth good to see you how are you
it's great to see you monica thanks so
much for having me today
absolutely so listen this is what
prompted me to invite you here
i was talking to a couple of my friends
back home in detroit who are small
business owners and you know detroit was
hit pretty hard
by the pandemic and as we're talking
they're telling me about the ppp that
they applied for
and other resources and i asked just out
of the blue hey are you a member of
you know the local chamber of commerce
and they were like well no i don't
i don't i never even thought about it
and i was like you know what i wonder
how many
other small businesses haven't even
thought about the chamber so let's kick
it off like this what is the purpose
of the chamber system in any city small
businesses you know they suffered quite
a bit
oh absolutely monica and i appreciate
you asking because
in some cases i think a chamber of
commerce is the best kept secret
unfortunately but
that's why i appreciate you having us
here today you know chambers of commerce
in the vegas chamber
is no different we support businesses
and employers of
all sizes and they support each other
and because we're committed to helping
our economy grow
so our chamber's purpose is to cultivate
growth and prosperity for in this case
all nevadans and the va you know the
vegas chamber and chambers of commerce
commerce around the world promote a
vibrant economy they help businesses
grow and thrive
and they really serve as a voice for
small businesses and are a champion of
really the greater community because a
lot of businesses like you said monica
they suffered so much
yes during the pandemic and and they
need
access to to these opportunities
mary beth let me jump in here what are
some of the benefits and be specific
because this is the stuff that people
don't know there are so many benefits to
being a member of a vegas chamber if
you're a business owner
well you're not kidding some of the
biggest benefits are um
you know we offer a brand new health
insurance program so
if you are trying to attract and retain
great employees you know everybody's
looking for benefits we want health
insurance we want
a 401k plan and that's just so important
to businesses to be able to
attract and retain those talented
employees
other so the health insurance plan the
401k plan we also have a partnership
at the vegas chamber with workforce
connections to help businesses find
trained employees it's the we're the
only chamber in the country that has a
one-stop business hub
that we also have through our
partnership with u.s bank
we have free professional coaches uh
through our partnership with them so
that's a great way
yeah for for you to get another resource
right at the chamber offices
so those are just a few of the benefits
we also
advocate for businesses in carson city
and
in washington dc as well that is so cool
okay now i know you named some of the
programs but
as a result of the pandemic specifically
has the chamber initiated
any special programs that can help small
businesses get a leg up right now
because i know
i heard a lot of people talk about ppp
okay yeah it's great that it's available
but how the heck do you apply who do you
go to
and is there any money still available
yeah well that's a great question too we
have
implemented several new brand new
programs for
businesses and it's easy to join our
chamber and monica we're giving away
temporary free memberships oh great go
to our website we'll give it to you for
free
just to just to see if it's something
that you find valuable and i know
people will but you know sometimes it's
scary to kind of dip your toe in the
water so
um that free trial membership it really
gives you the opportunity to experience
for yourself
all that the biggest chamber offers oh
i'm so glad you said that i had no idea
i checked out the website but i didn't
see that part and speaking of
uh mary beth we're almost out of time
how can folks get a hold of you
check out all the information and figure
out what they need
from you it is as easy as going to
vegaschamber.com we do have phone
numbers on our website as well so you
can call our office
yeah if you can't find what you're
looking for on the website like you said
that free membership just give us a call
at the office and we'll walk you through
it
wonderful thank you so much i knew you'd
be the perfect guest for this i
appreciate that and hopefully
it has helped out a lot of our local
businesses especially the small ones
trying to get themselves back together
again all right my friend take care and
have a great rest of your work week
thank you you too all right and don't
forget folks to catch my moj show
facebook live tonight
it's weeknights at 7 00 pm and we have
been
down for a couple of days because our
air conditioner i don't know if it was
struck by
lightning sharing or what the heck
happened but we were without air
for four days as the company was trying
to figure out what happened then they
said
they had to go into the wall and then
into the ceiling it's talking about
some stuff i couldn't even understand
that ac
lingo yeah but it was crazy this weather
has been
great for us yeah it's been a little
scary i gotta tell you
it doesn't come the caveat is it comes
with lightning and damaging winds and we
had a lot of that last night so
i'm glad that you kept the window shut
and didn't try to get a video
please be safe